dernier le parisien le journal le
parisien aujourd'hui en france révélé la
pelote de laurent contraint à monter un
internaute qui vous menacé de
décapitation vous êtes prof d'histoire
ça faisait tristement écho à sa mère
pattie décapité pour avoir donné un
cours sur la liberté d'expression
sauf que cette histoire laurent vous
auriez voulu qu'elle reste privé est
aujourd'hui votre famille est menacée à
cause de ces révélations
laurent joue sans et j'en ai mais j'ai
parlé un petit peu avec vous juste avant
je me sens extrêmement touchée
extrêmement stressé par cette affaire
stressé c'est pas le mot ces chants
colère pourquoi dites moi il est sûr que
les otages se couper du bois quand
j'étais en colère là il n'y a pas de
faux rien du tout mais je vais essayer
de rester calme qu'elle existe cette
affaire aurait dû être terminée c'est
pas laurent de koh lanta qu'on aurait dû
juger
pauvre gars qui malheureusement savait
pas de derrière derrière son clavier il
pouvait dire tout et n'importe quoi
parce que ce qui s'est passé l'an c'est
que ce pauvre gars voilà il a été
attrapé il s'est fait très vite
c'est ça donc il a été appréhendé par la
police at il vous avait condamné il a
été condamné à un an de prison ferme et
à 18 mois de prison dont six assortis
d'un sursis probatoire avec obligation
de soins et à une interdiction de se
rendre dans le département de l'isère et
d'entrer en relation avec vous vous en
faites
est ce que vous aviez vu ces menaces
moon à venir ne les avait signalé à
quelqu'un ou pas du tout je les ai
signalé dès que j'ai dû à la police chez
d'accord pour appeler le 17
et c'est vrai qu'ils m'ont conseillé
vivement de passer rapidement lendemain
avec le contexte actuel pour porter
plainte
donc ça c'est fait il a été arrêté très
rapidement d'accord il avait un vrai
profil si je peux permanent il avait
aucun profil etc
c'est pour ça que les choses se sont
quand même passé assez vite j'ai été
plus ou moins rassurer au mieux de la
semaine
la police m'a appelé en me disant qu'ils
n'avaient pas de profil visiblement pas
de casier non plus donc pour moi la
faire et ils allaient être jugés en fin
de semaine c'était réglé maintien et ma
femme n'avait pas été évoqué ma famille
non plus mon nom non plus ma photo non
plus d'accord et
jeudi les photos que voilà dans le
parisien voilà c'est ça dans le parisien
dont kenza ma photo votre adresse
enfin vos travaux vous habitez aux au 1
quai du mont pu donner mon adresse ou
carrément mon collège il y avait
également un gros bout de mon ma plainte
mon procès verbal comment ça se fait
comment ils peuvent se procurer sa loi
je fais de l'éducation civique avec mes
élèves et morale je leur apprends
justement que ces genres de choses ça ne
peut pas dans une république je leur
apprends des valeurs c'est interdit
c'est contre la loi il ya les deux plus
récents articles
depuis cet article paraît que vous êtes
sous protection policière je ne sais pas
depuis cet article j'étais avant
d'accord comme le gars a été arrêté il
ya plus de menaces sur moi d'accord il
ya par contre qu'est ce qui est plus
dangereux ce gars qui n'a pas de casier
ce gars qui a été arrêté et il ya plus
de bien à moins s'il avait des amis et
ses terrasses qui n'est pas le cas
monsieur le danger vient d'où c'est que
ma tête à paris partout laurent de koh
lanta etc dans le je suis une personne
se d'eau publics en ce moment là je suis
prof d'histoire je commence à cumuler
quand même pas mal de choses
donc oui qu'on mette en danger ma
famille il y avait des patrouilles
devant mon collège et des élèves qui
sont pas venus en cours en milieu de
semaine vous auriez voulu que cet
article ne paraissent pas imaginer mes
élèves il n'était pas inquiet il savait
pas que c'était que c'était moi en début
de semaine explique donc qu'il n'aurait
jamais dû le savoir
par contre voir ma tête en plein milieu
des journaux laurent avec le moka
décapitation vous imaginez que ouais
j'ai pas puisque le titre et ils
menacent de couper la tête de laurent le
prof d'histoire géo de koh lanta tout à
fait ça ça a été un drame pour vous je
suis pas comment mes élèves le gamin
grande ampleur ne sont revenus en quoi
ils ont essayé je n'avais pas forcément
envie de rentrer dans ces c'est pour moi
la sphère était terminée d'accord et je
vois pas pourquoi on au nom de al et de
vendre des journaux de faire de l'argent
on va aller mettre en première ligne
quelqu'un et le mettre en danger surtout
en ce moment où vous avez essayé de
contacter le parisien pour vous plaindre
pour leur dire que le spécialement ils
ont essayé de passer par la prod
d'accord lourdement insister lourdement
pour vous avoir je l'aurais j'aurais dit
que ça m'intéressait pas très
franchement moi le boss
si paul bezin nécessaire et des tons
laurent la juste ce soir vous vouliez
dire qu on vous lâche un peu et ça en
fait qu'on me lâche un peu puis surtout
qu'il ya des lois dans notre république
et qui ont au bout d'un moment il est
rare qu'on fasse quelque chose on tape
sur ce pauvre gars là qui
évidemment je suis pas en cause ce n'est
quoi que ce soit ouais bon il peut on
penser mais jeunes par ailleurs que
derrière son clavier dans les réseaux
c'est la jungle on peut faire ce qu'on
veut il ya ni ni foi ni loi eh ben je
leur apprends maintenant on peut pas et
des adultes
les journalistes qui sont censés avoir
une éthique ils sont censés avoir je
sais pas au moins les valeurs donc j'ai
pas se permettre de mettre quelqu'un en
danger en lourd contre mon gré dont je
suis vraiment heureux je suis outré je
suis indignée voilà je n'ai même pas de
mots ce que je pensais pas que c'était
possible
après vous allez me dire je suis naïf
non non non je suis un don quichotte
avec les moulins dont vous n'êtes pas
naïf parce que je comprends jours été
comme vous et je n'aurais pas compris
parce il au milieu ça
non non non je suis pas chez les people
ça va peut-être se voir un peu plus
souvent dos et laurent vous avez reçu
énormément de messages d'insultés comme
tout elle a plein dans koh lanta serré
cote depuis quelques saisons dans koh
lanta et à plein de gens qui reçoivent
des messages d'insultés remonte d'un
cran à chaque année bref c'est ça c'est
pour ça que je si j'avais un conseil ne
suis pas là pour faire du buzz par
rapport à la nature avait un conseil à
dire à la à la prod mais franchement
c'est il ya eu la fête des morts sur
l'émission là bien sûr bertrand cavale
non non pas dans la sphère belgrade
babin et depuis c'est vrai que les tests
physiques sont super encadré vrai que
passer des scanners du coeur etc
c'était un truc ou en ce sens à s'en
sortir et aimerait ça c'est super top et
on a attendu quand même qui est un
accident
j'aimerais bien qu'on n'attende pas
qu'ils aient suicide ou qu'ils aient
quelque chose de qui se passe
psychologiquement parlant parce que je
trouve que par rapport aux les lycéens
mastodonte koh lanta d'ailleurs je
trouve que l'encadrement dans ce domaine
là alors c'est peut-être moi dans
l'encadrement psychologique c'est à dire
par rapport à tout ce qui se passe
derrière sur les réseaux sociaux j'ai 50
ans ouais très franchement je me sens je
suis fort je pense avoir du recul assure
savoir de la distance par rapport à ça
et je peux vous dire pendant deux trois
jours ça tanguait ça tangue et fort je
ne pensais pas qu'il y avait une telle
haine
moi je dinosaures des réseaux sociaux
c'est parce que mes élèves qui
m'explique comment ça marche j'avais pas
d'instagram 1 ils ont formé un pour moi
mais je ne pensais pas que ça pouvait me
toucher autant j'ai eu deux jours de
difficiles
j'imagine un jeune un peu moins préparé
un peu moins un jour il y aura un
accident j'espère qu'ils attendra pas
que ça fasse comme ça s'est passé pour
avoir des tests un peu plus poussée et
peut-être essayer aussi de nous faire
une formation aux réseaux sociaux
le plus long que 30 minutes quoi alors
la production vous a répondu
alexia laroche-joubert excellente
productrice d'ailleurs de koh lanta je
suis content
mais elle dit je pense c'est un coup
stress du fait que son pv d'audition été
rendu public dans la presse votre pv
d'audition quand vous avez porté plainte
un il attaque à tout va
la presse les flics la production koh
lanta c'est un coup de sang c'est
complètement infondées surtout qu'il
n'ya aucun problème entre nous et
l'auront les réalités ce qu'on lui
propose de l'aide et qu'on lui donne un
numéro de téléphone d'un
psychothérapeute d'un psychothérapeute a
appelé la suite c'est le secret médical
et nous n'avons pas intervenir là dessus
que ce que vous avez à lui répondre
c'est vrai voilà et à ils ont une super
psy
koh lanta c'est vraiment la vérité
d'abord appelée elle était à tahiti
ouais avec un peu nu j'ai dit oh
heureusement que j'avais pas quelque
chose de grave
très franchement comme si de tahiti bref
vous appelle m'appelle c'est vrai que
c'est un soutien psychologique qui me
semble un peu léger ont longtemps
lointain voit pas d'accord bon après je
ne vais pas cracher dans la soupe j'ai
participé à cette émission
mais je préfère amicalement leur dire
qu'à mon avis il ya une faille et qu'un
jour il y aura quelque chose attendons
pas qu'ils aient un accident ou puis
vraiment quelque chose qui se passe des
autres candidats vous ont dit que
c'était compliqué pour eux et qu'ils
avaient beaucoup de plaintes et que
c'était compliqué de sortir de
l'aventuré de sentir un peu sonne
évidemment quand on voit et régis
l'année dernière je bien sûr j'ai une
pensée pour lui parce que moi à mon
petit niveau
j'ai vécu ça pendant peu de temps parce
que j'ai pas trop trop fait de conneries
sur koh lanta donc ça va mais j'imagine
pas il a dû quitter son boulot sa femme
sa fille était menacée de viol enfin je
vous comprends pas qu'on puisse arriver
à de telles extrémités et que ouais
cette année ça tombe bien parce que je
il ya eu à faire sur samuel pâtit etc je
pense que ça se serait noyé et que mon
avis on referiez koh lanta ou ce que
vous regrettez ou pas je regrette pas de
l'avoir fait ça a été une super aventure
franchement sur place par contre là prêt
j'ai un genou en moins donc à mon avis
les héros c'est fini ce serait plutôt
les héros pour moi d'accord et puis non
franchement c'est du stress avant chaque
émission à quelle sauce ça va être
montée quelle sauce on va être mangé
comment ça va réagir par la suite j'ai
pas j'ai pas aimé voilà par contre l'
aventure sur place c'est exceptionnel
c'est vraiment une avant coralie c'est
tout ce qui est tout ce qu'il ya autour
j'ai jamais j'ai juste très c'est ça
devrait être un plaisir
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes stressé
de tout ce qui se passe autour de vous
de toutes les insu de tout ce qui s'est
passé de cet article est sorti pour
votre famille et ses stress est sage et
je vous le dis j'ai eu deux jours de
temps vraiment après c'était les limites
si on va dire d'accord gaiters chez paul
trop comment ça marche et ils sont une
quinzaine il vous attaque sont dus à une
meute là c'est pareil vous avez une
formation 30 minutes chaque candidat
avec à peu près ça c'est pas très loin
formation qu'est ce qui vous dit
cependant la formation de koh lanta ça
c'est intéressant pour nos
téléspectateurs
ils vous disent quoi quand ils vous
forme il faut pas faire attention à ce
qui se passe ouais évitez de lire a même
un minimum les réseaux sociaux d'accord
ne surtout pas répondre
d'accord c'est vraiment un gros problème
on les appelle d'accord donc à vous les
appelez j'ai je renvoyais 1 c'était le
soir donc je leur ai envoyé un texto tu
veux redire là-dessus gilles verdez le
témoignage de laurent est absolument
passionnant et c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup de candidats de cette saison de
la précédente qui sont vraiment menacés
sur les réseaux ça monte en tension et
ça devient préoccupant après sur la
sphère du procès-verbal laurence c'est
le boulot des journalistes du parisien
ils ont une plainte que vous avez déposé
le l'ingénieur qui vous a menacé a été
incarcéré donc c'est pas une petite
affaire c'est pas un farfelu
ils ont le procès verbal et comme elle
je suis d'accord avec vous mais le
secret de l'instruction le secret de
l'enquêté
je veux bien c'est interdit je suis bien
d'accord tout le monde le fait c'est pas
parce que tout le monde le fait on est
obligé de le faire
bon moi très franchement je suis pas
d'accord avec vous le secret de
l'intruction cevital c'est essentiel
dans notre démocratie si on peut faire
maintenant n'importe quoi elle est où
les types des journalistes vous avez
j'espère vous avez des limites dans
votre émission
et vous avez un certain regard et c'est
sûr après moral juste après après c'est
vrai que ce que dit gilles énorme je
suis un peu d'accord et vous voulez la
vérité mais c'est vrai que les journées
ils vont dire on fait juste notre
travail lui mais c'est vrai que là qu'on
s'a mis en danger la vie est ce qu'un
journaliste est un voleur de documents
est ce qu'un journaliste doit à les
soudoyer je ne sais qui on pourra accès
à mon procès verbaux avait été rédacteur
en chef du parisien déprimé alors emparé
pour lui laurent - en tant que rédacteur
en chef du parisien j'aurais publié
l'article je vous dis franchement ça
fasse part et sénégal oui à l'organe le
les procès verbaux y d'abord bien
soudoyer n'y a pas d'argent il les
obtient par leurs sources et ça fait
partie du métier du fait diversier
d'obtenir sa et revient et 10g le procès
verbal de langeais sa plainte regard à
ce qu'il l'a alors par des avocats des
juges des policiers voilà nicolas
pernikoff jeter leurs ailerons
on va voir l'euro et nicolas
laurent bon maintenant vous êtes connus
vous êtes passé à la télé ça c'est aussi
les risques
je trouve que le parisien la croche est
un peu est un peu art par contre il ya
un point positif laurent et vous pouvez
vous féliciter pour ça aujourd'hui
quelqu'un été condamné pour vous avoir
dit des choses terribles sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas de gendarmes des réseaux
sociaux ni en france ni en europe ni
dans le monde
nous on a un csa en france ne pas fermer
un peu quoi donc aujourd'hui il faut
quand même savoir que s'il ya un mec qui
dit une connerie qui vous menace il peut
être condamné il serait de condamner
c'est un ingénieur mais il a été
condamné à 12 mois de prison ferme
incroyable je trouve ça formidable et
grâce à cet article maintenant mais
laurent il est tout le monde le sait
avec n'est pas content q qu'est-ce qui
est le plus dangereux pour moi très
franchement je m'éloigne est-ce que
c'est ce mec qu'a pas de casier etc qui
a fait ça parce qu'il est autant crs
mais bien dans sa vie rien au départ ou
non mais mais quand le parisien mais ma
tête en une et c'est à l'enquêté pas
terminé on sait pas s'il a de la famille
ou s'il a des amis etc
il ya des flics qui tourne autour de
l'équipe e delà de l'école de ma fille
je suis jeune je regrette
avec ce qui s'est passé avec samuel
pâtit etc je demanderai un petit peu
plus du pudeur à la presse ou au moins
un petit peu comment dirais-je un peu de
recul et de se dire avec ce qui se passe
en ce moment il ya eu les églises etc
le mec des faits exposés ils passent à
la télé on va peut-être évité d'exposer
lui et sa famille mais visiblement pour
vendre du papier jeu je moi je suis
énervé d'entendre ça je pensais avoir un
peu plus de soutien ou en tout cas moi
je suis chez naïve suis ici je suis donc
à chiottes non là donc ils n'ont donc
les choses et le monde parce qu'il a eu
à faire samuel pâtit que la presse a
réagi aussi
ciel mer moi je suis désolé je comprends
tout à fait laurent parce que c'est pas
parce que a été arrêté que c'est ça
quand ça consiste pas une sorte d'appel
aux autres à s'attaquer à laurent je
comprends très bien que sans se presser
lui et sa famille elle échoué ce régime
la liberté de cette de la presse
s'arrête là où commence le le danger la
mise en danger des des autres dans la
période actuelle
tout ça pour une info comme c'est une
petite info tu me met en danger toute
une famille tout ça pour sortir un petit
scoop
voilà qui met en danger laurent et sa
famille franchement les esprits comme ça
tu mets dans ton placard étaient
contents les mène dans ton placarde pas
les sortir je suis surtout que si je
peux me permettre les ignorants très
franchement moi je parle par rapport je
suis victime dans ce truc et mais je
pense aux à l'accusé bien sûr est ce
qu'il a été jugé simplement parce que il
a menacé un prof etc ou est-ce qu'il a
très franchement tu es jugé parce qu'il
a proféré des menaces à laurent de koh
lanta
alors on pourra interroger je suis pas
je suis pas juge j'ai l'impression c'est
lourd alors peut-être qu'un mois je
voulais pas que ça soit un exemple je
voulais qu'il soit jugé pour ce qu'il a
fait et non pas parce qu'il a attaqué le
rang de koh lanta ou un personnage
public ou parce qu'il ya une pression
médiatique autour de tout ça on va dire
tiens on va taper sur la table pour
faire 22 alors je vous dire pour ceux
qui nous rejoignent à 21h02 sur ces 8 on
détourne direct alors entre koh lanta
qui a sorti vendredi qu'a reçu des
menaces sur les réseaux sociaux il a été
porté plainte la plante est sorti dans
le parisien alors que laurent ne voulait
pas du tout et après cela la personne
qui vous a menacé a écopé d'un an de
prison ferme et 18 mois de prison dont
six assortis d'un sursis probatoire
c'est à dire une grosse grosse peine et
l'orangé c'est parce que vous vouliez
j'suis pas vu à la base je n'aime pas je
peux pas juger je suis pas juge mais je
me dis j'espère très franchement que sa
page où jouer pour lui aussi parce que
moi ça me met en danger ma famille
également
mais il faut voir les de l'autre côté
également est ce qu'il a été jugé comme
comment ils auraient été jugées
normalement jeu j'essaie dans ma tête
quelque part jouent là vous et ça me
gêne tévané pourquoi j'aimerais
comprendre laurent vous mêler la
production à ça c'est ce qui fait écho
dans la presse en disant notamment que
la production contrôler vos réseaux
sociaux
alexia laroche joubert vous a répondu en
disant que c'était totalement faux et en
disant qu'elle a même essayé de vous
appeler plusieurs fois au téléphone et
que vous n'avez pas répondu parce que
madame laroche joubert m'a appelé trois
jours après le seul moyen vraiment un
message et caleçons france et de
diminuer ses données à jour même de
tahiti avec un message de soutien la
faune derrière toi et c'était un accès
libre à moi je vais pas répondu pourquoi
parce que je les ai vus
répondre à ma place dans le parisien en
disant que j'étais quelqu'un de solide
qui prenaient beaucoup de distance par
rapport à ça j'ai jamais communiqué avec
elle
ou est-ce qu'elles sortent quelques
j'étais dans la panique en début de
semaine il y avait des filles qui
m'accompagnait la bac qui m'accompagne à
monbahus très franchement solide ou à ce
moment là non pas qu on a parlé à ma
place elle a dit que ça n'avait pas de
rapport avec koh lanta ce qui est pas
vraiment vrai parce que le gars est venu
saumon d'instagram laurent koh lanta il
est parvenu à les chercher un truc de 17
chez huawei donc voilà c'est à voir s à
avoir rien tapia fraude
simplement je vous dis clairement je me
suis pas senti en début de semaine super
soutenu d'accord quand vous avez vu ce
papier vous êtes dit c'est une cata pour
moi vous avez vu le papier du parisien
vous êtes dit c'est pas du tout ce que
je voulais le mercredi quand on m'a dit
qu'il était arrêté que visiblement il
n'y avait pas de danger pour ma famille
et qu'on allait sans doute en fin de
semaine levé le système etc
j'étais rassuré d'accord et quand j'ai
vu l'article bing pour tout vous dire
j'avais quand même vu le dauphiné
d'accord le dauphiné libéré
j'avais beaucoup de mes élèves qui
avaient peur donc je leur ai dit je veux
bien faire un communiqué avec vous comme
quoi tout est rentré dans l'homme
l'homme a été arrêté et on en parle plus
quoi lots dans juste il n'y a pas une
chose importante c'est la gestion des
candidats après les émissions de télé
réalité on avait déjà ce problème avec
avec 6 heures ils savaient qu'ils sont
laissés dans la nature il y a personne
pour vous honnêtement non voilà et ça
c'est pareil à bas quand je faisais des
téléréalités il faut maintenant que les
boîtes de prod prennent conscience
qu'avec les réseaux sociaux s'est
amplifiée démultiplier qu'aujourd'hui si
on vous protège pas ça va être compliqué
pour vous et pour beaucoup d'autres
et puis c'est koh lanta c'est énoncer la
plus concise et non pas voilà oui je
trouve que le rapport mais qu'a voulu
faire une connerie comme ça sur les
réseaux sociaux
peut-être qui n'est pas aisé parlement
ce qui marque et le mec qui s'est pris
un an de prison et peut-être que la
panamera et veut réfléchir
hélas pour le bol il faudrait qu'au
népal se souvenant a pris la tasse à
gemena des gaps tête et amis qui sont un
pote à lui et tout je sais qui est ce
que c'est juste
est-ce qu'il doit y avoir une pression
médiatique etc quand il ya un jugement
je pense pas on attend à la rigueur que
la chose se terminer à ce moment là on
peut éventuellement en parler laurent
peut pas attaquer le journal c'est comme
ça c'est ce qu'on fait ah bon d'accord
vous attaquer le journal le parisien on
ne peut pas en parler parce que c'est un
grave ont le secret de l'instruction sur
mais le parisien à ses sourcils en
parlera certainement
juste laurent dernière dernière question
laurent est ce que c'est compliqué
aujourd'hui d'exercer pour vous en tant
que prof d'histoire avec tout ce qui
s'est passé et puis en plus en tant que
anciens candidats de koh lanta
est-ce que c'est compliqué ou pas je
suis pas en zone prioritaire je suis pas
en zone sensible d'accord donc je vais
pas mais j'ai beaucoup de mes collègues
etc qui font un métier difficile
il ya beau mot pourra être prof c'est le
plus beau métier du monde
on est au centre du système éducatif on
nous met beaucoup beaucoup de choses
aujourd'hui sur le dos en disant que
vraiment et j'ai passé des mots j'ai
l'impression c'est beaucoup de mots et
on reste un petit peu démunis on parlait
de la formation de de koh lanta par
rapport aux réseaux sociaux etc
mais alors je parlerai même pas de la
formation de profs on nous demande de
faire de l'éducation civique et morale
sur les réseaux des dix mois au début de
koh lanta c'est mes élèves qui
m'apprenait à comment instagram
fonctionner est ce que est ce qu'on
considérait un des jeunes ou à des moins
jeunes de faire koh lanta ou pas du tout
s'ils n'ont pas les reins solides
cécile sont fort si c'est vraiment le
rêve d'une autre vie etc
ils passeront ils sont peut-être plus
avant tu est habituellement un vieux con
qui découvre un peu les réseaux quoi
donc peut-être que c'est un petit peu
lors leur milieu et d'ailleurs je crois
que koh lanta c'est une majorité de
jeunes qui regardent
je suis surpris par sa se sert plus et
les îles sont ces les personnes les plus
fragiles ben là et ce qu'ils auraient
pas également l'accompagnement je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas moi je me
trouve qu'en tant que prof on n'a pas
forcément les billes pour pouvoir
on va peut-être nous les donner en
marquer un ben moi je suis prof
d'histoire donc je fais une formation ma
grande formation c'est l'histoire rien
ne suit pas éducation civique on nous
met en plus comprenez vous la colère de
laurent contre la presse oui à 86% non à
14% donc toutes les personnes à à la
majorité pensent comme vous un laurent
et sont un peu énervés oui vraiment moi
juste j'aimerais d'abord laurent
j'aimerais pas être à votre place est la
question que je me pose c'est pourquoi
en fait pour quand on met un mec en
prison un an c'est énorme ça que j'ai du
mal à beaucoup un an pourquoi on n'a pas
pris le temps de voir le profil du gua
est-ce que c'est un cinglé est-ce qu'il
est déséquilibré avant de le mettre un
en prison pour servir d'exemples comme
vous avez dit sachant très bien que le
mot décapité en ce moment et même tout
le temps il faut pas le faire et nicolas
l'a dit d'accord mais moi pour moi un an
je suis comme toi pour moi c'est trop un
an de prison parce que enfin exacte et
roger une clameur et justice
la vie dans la prison cet hymne
peut-être qu'on va lui donner le motif
pourquoi il est rentré dans la prison je
vais essayer de faire vite on va lui
dire quand j'étais jeune on a fini le
sujet facile a dit décapité donc là dans
la prison il va rencontrer des gens peut
être néfaste pourquoi il va sortir dans
un ample que dans un autre c'est ce qu'a
dit laurent on sera pas là que rené
savoir le rethélois là pour savoir ce
qu'ils valent là dedans est tout à leur
demande à sa sortie et deuxième plans là
c'est courage ils essaient pour tous les
spécialistes de la presse est un truc
que je comprends pas c'est qu'on dit on
est obligé de faire voir que la tête on
a le droit c'est légal moi j'aimerais
bien aussi que la presse elle fasse voir
la tête de toutes ces [ __ ] qui
violent etc assassines des jeunes filles
ou qu'aux caisses
l'exemple de victorine par exemple l'a
dernièrement victorine sf assassiné
quand l'été faire son footing la presse
elle refuse de mettre la tête du mec qui
l'a assassiné
pourquoi on met ta tête à toi et
pourquoi mais pas l'âge et les envies
alors expliquez moi j'aimerais bien
comprendre
raymonde d'abord j'ai pas dit que
c'était légal laurent va attaquer et il
peut gagner parce que vous direz que on
a utilisé vous avez mais mais mais je
défends le travail des journalistes
raymond parce que là c'est une affaire
qui est jugée il y a là affaire qui est
jugée il est victime s'est établie on
n'est pas dans le cadre où il ya un
suspect ou l'a fait pourquoi gentil à
vous parle d'eux mais elle pense qu'elle
c'est un métier très franchement je sais
plus quelle hauteur le disait ah c'est
un métier où chacun navigue à vue
d'accord et que ce pur simple boussole
sa conscience c'est quand même
inquiétant alors je sais un
contre-pouvoir c'est certain je la
liberté de la presse est exceptionnel
mais je pense que les journalistes ont
des droits c'est super ils ont également
des devoirs
très franchement y'a un moment là moi
j'apprends tous les matins à mes élèves
les valeurs de la république les choses
à faire et que des journalistes se
disent mais nous écouter tout le monde
le fait c'est quelque chose qui se fait
naturellement
on va pas commencer à s'offusquer ou
faire les vierges effarouchées moi ça me
choque parce que je suis peut-être comme
les français ils découvrent peut-être
qu'on peut en effet aller se procurer le
procès verbal alors je sais même pas
comment on peut faire un mois je pensais
que c'était complètement interdite et
que ce jeu j'aime aussi